good morning John thanks a lot for your
video yesterday I wished that I could
say that it prevented me from constantly
refreshing my feet last night it did not
I'm still kind of doing it we are very
slow at counting votes in Montana I also
want to tell you about an idea that me
and some friends have had in a similar
vein which is why I'm wearing a sport
coat today earlier this year I posted a
really bad idea on Twitter it said what
if you had to go to a place to watch a
YouTube video
the most common response to this of
course was thanks I hate it look I
understand but just because that idea is
bad doesn't mean you shouldn't get
obsessed with it and think about it for
eight months and then finally do some
things that's a little bit of different
version will get there so I love the
Internet I love the social nature of the
Internet the good interesting social
things the Internet has done I love
nerdfighteria now I feel like a little
bit maybe the pendulum has swung too far
and now I'm suddenly much more
interested in innovating in the space of
physical experiences so that's one piece
the other piece is you might remember a
long time ago I did an internet trivia
game called truth or fail and it was
great but relied on YouTube annotations
and so is now literally impossible but
what if you could only watch truth or
fail if you went to a physical place and
I know what you're thinking now you're
thinking Hank you just have been in pub
trivia like that's also already a fan so
we have but also I think this idea
changes if you look at it from different
angles so truth or fail trivia it's a
thing it exists it's available now and
it's available in various forums but
let's talk a little bit about what it is
complexly our production company that as
scishow and crash course puts together a
bunch of questions there's a standard
version which is like any other pub
trivia so it's hosted by a person in the
place where you are it comes with a very
pretty slideshow designed by psy shows
Haruka Matsushima and those slides have
the questions on it which is great with
one of my big pub trivia pet peeves is
that sometimes you can't hear the
questions and some people can't hear
well at all and so it's very hard to
play if you don't hear the question
there's also the hosted version which is
a full-length five round trivia all
hosted by people who are on the TVs
people include me but also other hosts
of scishow all you need is somebody to
set it up push play on the video and
then do the scoring both of those
packages have one guest video round
that's gonna be guest hosted by a bunch
of my internet friends but also I think
that like bars aren't the only place
where this is a good
eeeh and we've been thinking about it in
like the bar frame for too long and so
we've got a pub package which is a
weekly subscription where you get a new
one every week but there's also a school
package where you buy it a semester at a
time so basically for the cost of
bringing 1/10 of a medium popular band
from the 2000s to the campus to play for
one 90-minute set you can get a whole
semester of trivia the reason I'm so
excited about truth or filled trivia
like excited enough to add it to the
list of things that I'm doing is just
the idea of friends coming together to
meet at a place in a space and have
these physical experiences that are a
little bit mediated so not all of the
social pressure is on you to make you
make these thing interesting and also
with pub trivia there's like a very good
reason to not look at your phone because
you could be cheating so you have to not
look at your phone for a while and
phones are great don't get me wrong the
Internet is great so is just being dumb
with some folks for a while like
learning and connecting and building
community and winning and losing and
learning things about each other thanks
to the hard work of a lot of great
people this is the thing that's gonna be
in the world if you're interested in us
letting you know if truth or filled
trivia shows up nearby you there's a
survey down in the description that is
very quick and easy to fill out and if
you want to get a business or school or
organization that you work with involved
there is also a survey in the
description for you now there's also a
chance that no one wants this and if not
enough people sign up we won't be able
to do it so sails are open now at
truther feel calm for a low introductory
price and the trivia starts going out in
early 2019 thanks John I'll see you
tomorrow